Hey youtubers it’s Charlie.
Since you guys have been asking for a nice
long Game of Thrones Martell video I thought
I’d talk about what’s happening with them
on the show in season 4 as well as in the
books.
I’m also developing a new Game Of Thrones
companion show that will debut when the show
comes back.
They’re will be all kinds of fun stuff and
weekly giveaways.
I’ll be posting a separate video later explaining
how it’s going to work.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
So In case you’re not caught up with the
books and you don’t want spoilers I’ll
let you know when to turn the volume down.
Here we go House Martell during Season 4 starting
off with number 1 the cast.
There will be two members representing House
Martell and Dorne during Season 4 including
Pedro Pascal as Oberyn Martell the Red Viper.
and Indira Varma as Ellaria Sand, one of his
lovers and mother of four of the 8 sand snakes.
The Red Viper’s bastard daughters.
Because the show condenses so much of the
book story for time both characters will only
be in a few episodes despite being fairly
significant to the plot of Book 3.
2, let’s talk about their episodes.
Pretty much all of Oberyn’s scenes will
be in King’s Landing with Tyrion and the
other members of the small council.
Most notably Tywin.
There’s even been some behind the scenes
set photos of Pedro Pascal in costume.
Interestingly enough, there were also a lot
of pictures of him hanging out with Lena Headey
in real life.
In case anyone wants to start a Red Viper
Cersei ship.
Ellaria is like Oberyn’s Shae, except she’s
not a hooker.
She’ll appear in a few of Oberyn’s scenes,
but she won’t be a large part of Oberyn’s
secret mission.
You can expect some potential scenes with
Sansa, Cersei and Shae though.
3 the backstory
There’s a really deep history between the
Lannisters and the Martell’s that goes all
the way back to Robert’s Rebellion.
Oberyn’s sister Elia was Prince Rhaegar’s
wife.
She was killed by The Mountain and the whole
thing was covered up by Tywin Lannister so
that it wouldn’t start another war with
Dorne.
Because Tyrion granted the Martell’s a seat
on the Small Council in exchange for help
during the battle of blackwater in season
2, Oberyn’s brother Doran uses that as an
opportunity for them to learn the truth of
Elia’s death.
As a result of Sherlocking his way around
King’s Landing, Oberyn gets caught up in
the events of the purple wedding and tyrion’s
fate.
So look forward to some good Pedro Pascal
Peter Dinklage scenes.
The funny thing is that by the time Oberyn
makes it to King’s Landing, Tyrion has already
fallen from grace.
House Martell and Dorne really become more
of a destination for the story in a feast
for crows, dance with dragons and winds of
winter.
Number 4, Here’s where we need to talk about
what’s going on with them in Winds of Winter.
This will be about things in the books, not
the show.
So if you don’t want potential spoilers
turn the volume down now.
4, the sand snakes.
House Martell and the sand snakes become much
more physically present in Kings Landing during
winds of winter.
They’re all part of a larger espionage mission
to learn more about the Lannister’s plot
to get rid of Prince Doran.
Nymeria takes Oberyn’s seat on the small
council, Tyene poses as a septa to try and
get information from the High Sparrow.
That’s the same High Sparrow that makes
Cersei march naked through the streets.
Sarella poses as a maester in training in
Oldtown to try and get more information about
the lannister plot and Obara hunts for the
Darkstar.
Remember he maimed Mrycella after their plot
to crown her queen of westeros failed.
The really cool thing I always liked about
them were that they felt so much more organized
and effective than the brave companions or
the brotherhood without banners.
I guess you could say that the faceless ones
in the east are more fearsome, but the Sand
Snakes are my favorite westerosi supergroup.
Number 5, the east.
The Martells storyline in the east is almost
non-existent after what happens to quentyn,
so most of their storyline will follow the
sand snakes in Kings Landing
Number 6, the mummers dragon.
Because House Martell has been neutral during
the war of the five kings, whoever wants to
take the iron throne from the lannisters will
need their help.
Because Aegon is alive, they also send Arianne
to find out if he is really Aegon.
Because that would make him Prince Doran’s
nephew.
I haven’t seen any evidence to contradict
that he really is Aegon, so I think that during
Winds of Winter he and Jon Connington will
join forces with dorne against the lannisters.
Number 7, dance of the dragons round 2.
Aegon’s plan to claim the throne is also
in direct conflict with daenerys.
Remember the short story the dance of the
dragons that george rr martin just published.
I think that will also end up happening again.
But maybe not until dream of spring.
The real story to pay attention to is Aegon
and the Martell’s plan to take control of
westeros, let me know how you think it will
go down.
Personally I think it will leave them weaker
than ever.
Remember how the original dance of the dragons
ended.
Nobody really ends up winning in a war.
One side just ends up losing a little bit
less than the other side.
Spoilers over, you can turn the volume back
up.
Like I said before, I’m working on a new
bonus show that will be part of the game of
thrones videos I do when the show comes back.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Click here to learn more about those bonus
videos.
And click here to get my review of that new
dance of the dragons short story.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!